HENRY: Time travel.
It's not a super power.
It's a disability.
It's what's wrong with me.
Can I help you?
Henry.
Sorry, I don't know--
Clare.
So we've met, then.
Yes.
CLARE: We just...
happened to each other.
In the wrong order.
HENRY: Any hobbies?
I'm your future wife.
There are three things
that I got good at to survive.
Running.
Fighting.
And stealing.
The danger isn't the worst.
Christmas is the worst.
CLARE: There are days
he keeps going back to.
HENRY: I can't control it.
And I hate to be
where she's not.
I'm always going,
and she can't follow.
This is me,
changing the future.
HENRY: I have tried
to change it.
Trust me, you can't.
YOUNG HENRY:
Mom!
Hi everyone.
-Who the hell are you?
-Who's he look like?
Ay, dios mio.
CLARE: I love Henry more
than I could ever love
anyone else.
So then, where is he?
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
HENRY: I don't have very long.
Nobody has very long.
I think I'm going.
No, not now.
I love you.
CLARE: Why is love
intensified by absence?